[Applause]
we all know the icon of elvis
but what always fascinates me are the
intricacies of the human being he he was
the american dream
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's an amazing thing but that's
also problematic
when it comes to exploring his life as
elvis said
mighty big stage it's very hard
to live up to an image
and austin went on an extraordinary
three-year journey
to discover the human being some people
wanted to put me in jail because the way
i was moving
i started with just being a sponge you
know reading every book that i could get
my hands on watching everything and
every image that i possibly
could find treating him like a detective
and then also working with a number of
different vocal coaches on singing and
working on that because voice is so
important with him
it's just been an incredible joy to see
austin create such a dynamic portrayal
of elvis
it's been a long time baby i have to say
you could not take your eyes off of
austin butler no matter what the scene
was
whether he's up on stage performing
singing full on full tilt the close to
the best dedication was impressive right
off the bat you want to do them justice
and you want to honor them in their life
he was such an extraordinary human being
larger than life itself has been that
thing of how do you climb mount everest
just one step at a time
[Music]
you